In the many years since Home Alone's release
in 1990, it's become evident that while Kevin
McAllister's solo Yuletide adventures are still
tremendously fun to watch, there are a lot of
things about this film that are a little too
bizarre, illogical, or even downright disturbing.
If you're a kid watching Home Alone,
Kevin's dialogue feels almost aspirational.
The things he says to his parents and other
family members are the kinds of things we
all wished we could say when we were young,
but probably never had the nerve to do so.
When his mom tells him to leave
her room, for example, he responds:
"Hang up the phone and make me why don’t ya."
And then when she tells him to go upstairs after
he shoves his brother Buzz in
the kitchen, he shouts back:
"I am upstairs, dummy!"
Granted, Kevin is in the midst of being punished
when he says this, but still, calling your mom a
"dummy" and suffering zero consequences would've
felt like a dream for young moviegoers. However,
as an adult, it's a little hard to overlook
just how rude Kevin is, and how his parents
either ignore it or laugh it off. To be fair, most
of the other McCallister kids are just as bad,
if not worse. So Kevin doesn't really stand
out that much in comparison, making the idea
of traveling to Paris with so many disrespectful
kids sound more like a nightmare than a vacation.
Still, considering that Kevin is the
protagonist, it's a little weird that
he's characterized as being just as unpleasant to
be around as the rest of the kids in his family.
Even if you put aside the fact that the
McCallisters have clearly spent a small fortune
decorating every inch of their expansive house for
a holiday they're not even going to be home for,
have you ever taken a close look at the rest
of that house? It's not just the seasonal
decorations that make it feel festive. The
entire interior design scheme seems to have
been planned around the holiday. Just consider
the green kitchen counters and red pots and pans,
or the red-green-and-white patterned
wallpaper covering the walls of nearly
every room and hallway. And there's
also the parents' red bedspread,
the framed red flowers on their walls, and the
red and green furniture in the living room.
The kitchen floor is red. The dining room
walls are red. The upstairs walls are green.
The living room has a red and white rug on the
floor and green curtains framing the windows.
Even the telephone is green. From lampshades
to bathrobes to prominently placed teapots,
it's hard to find a single surface or person in
the McCallister house that isn't decked out for
the holidays all the time. After living in such
a festive home year-round, it's no wonder the
McCallister children seem to be fresh out of
Christmas cheer by the time December arrives.
When Kevin shoves Buzz for saying
he ate Kevin's entire cheese pizza,
Buzz falls into some cups of milk,
which spill all over the passports
and airline tickets on the kitchen counter.
The next morning, during the hubbub to get
everyone out of the house and to the airport
on time, Kevin's dad Peter mentions that the
passports are in the microwave, where
he put them in order to dry them off.
This microwave plan was probably a bad idea
for several reasons. Although passports in
1990 wouldn't have had the radio frequency
identification chips contained in modern
passports, which could've caused them to burst
into flames in the microwave, they still would've
had plastic covers, which could've melted.
The passports also would've contained small
amounts of metal in the foil stamping on their
covers and the inner security features, which
would've caused them to catch fire. Peter's lucky
he didn't cause the whole trip to go up in flames.
Although at least in that case, Kevin wouldn't
have accidentally been left at home by himself.
Kevin's mom Kate realizes on the plane that she
left Kevin behind, and the first thing she does
after landing is wrestle a payphone away from
a French woman so that she can call the police.
What follows is a frustrating series of
conversations as Kate gets transferred
from one department to another and conveys her
story over and over to bored officers who seem
more interested in preparing for Christmas
than in ensuring a child's safety. If you're
a kid watching this scene, it's easy to get
annoyed at the police, and especially at the
officer who later goes to the McCallister house,
knocks once, then gives up and leaves when no one
answers the door. Surely this police department
is the height of professional incompetence,
right? As it turns out, though, maybe not.
When Kate calls, all she says each time is:
"Yeah hi look,
I'm calling from Paris. I
have a son who's home alone.
Our phones there are out of order so I'd like
somebody to go over to our house and tell him
that we're coming home to get him."
She never mentions Kevin's age, or the fact
that he's not supposed to be alone. Instead,
she comes across as an overprotective
parent who purposely left her teenager
at home and now wants the police to make sure
he isn't throwing a rager while she's away.
No wonder the police didn't bother investigating
further when Kevin didn't answer the door.
It can seem illogical that Kevin never
calls the police until the end of the movie,
choosing instead to construct an elaborate
series of booby traps to protect himself.
But by Kevin's logic, it actually makes sense.
He thinks he made his family disappear by magic,
and when he later encounters the Wet Bandits,
he recognizes Harry as the police officer who
visited his house earlier. Police can't
help with a magically disappearing family,
and they may in fact be the bad
guys if Harry is one of them.
But it's less clear why the pizza guy doesn't call
911 after he delivers a pie to the McCallister
home and Kevin uses the Angels with Filthy Souls
video to trick him into believing someone is
trying to kill him. The ruse clearly works,
but then nothing happens. If he's under the
impression that one of his customers just tried to
kill him, you'd think that he'd call the police,
or at least report it to his manager, who could
pass the incident along to the authorities.
But it appears that instead he just keeps it
to himself and goes about the rest of his day.
During the break-in extravaganza at the
end of the film, Kevin knows to be ready
because the Wet Bandits inadvertently
tell him to expect them at nine o'clock.
But when he sets up his elaborate fake party,
all he knows is that two creepy guys in a van
were hanging around outside his house earlier in
the day. He had no way of knowing what time they'd
be coming back, or if they were even planning
on returning at all. Yet he somehow managed
to be enthusiastically dancing at the precise
moment when Harry and Marv drove by that night.
Either Kevin was incredibly lucky with his
timing, or he'd already been partying for
hours with his cardboard friends by the
time the Wet Bandits finally returned.
The most plausible explanation is that
he had the whole party setup ready to
go as soon as their van turned onto his
street, kept a close watch, and it was
a lot less complicated than it appeared
for him to put all the cutouts in motion.
But it's more fun to imagine that he was just
rocking out with his inanimate guests all day.
Although the church scene between Kevin
and Old Man Marley is heartwarming,
it's hard not to notice that it's also a
little odd while watching it as an adult.
Even if you put aside the fact that Kevin is in
a church an hour before the Wet Bandits are due
to arrive and he has to run home in order to
make his battle plan work in time, there are
still a few elements about this scene that are
kind of strange when you examine them closely.
It makes sense that Old Man Marley would come over
to introduce himself to Kevin and tell him that
he doesn't need to be afraid of him. After all,
it would've been hard for him to miss his young
neighbor fleeing from him in terror earlier in the
movie. However, it's a little bizarre that Marley
then proceeds to unload all of his troubles with
his estranged son onto a second-grader he's only
just met and whose parents are nowhere in sight.
Of course, we understand that Marley means well,
especially when he comes to Kevin's rescue
at the end of the film, but typically adults
don't have impromptu heart-to-hearts with
unaccompanied minors they don't know.
Of the many traps Kevin sets for the Wet
Bandits, one that could've proved disastrous is
the electric charcoal starter that he hangs from
the front doorknob. The idea behind it is simple,
even if the physics are a little advanced for
a second-grader. Kevin plugs in the starter
inside the house, hangs it on the indoor metal
knob, which conducts the heat to the outdoor
knob and ultimately sears an impression of
itself onto an unsuspecting Harry's hand.
After Harry gives up on the front entrance, Kevin
leaves the starter plugged in and hanging on the
door. Keeping in mind that it had already been on
the door for about an hour before Harry showed up,
that starter was probably left unattended for at
least a couple hours before Kevin turned it off.
In that time, there would've
been a serious risk of the door,
and subsequently the entire
house, catching on fire.
"It's pretty cool that you
didn't burn the place down."
The traps that Kevin sets for the Wet Bandits at
the end of the movie all seem like delightfully
funny pranks when you're a kid. But as an
adult, it's easy to see the many ways they
could've resulted in death. Both criminals
take some serious blows to their heads and
the rest of their bodies during the home invasion
sequence, any one of which could've proved lethal.
First, there's the iron dropped on Marv's face
via the laundry shoot, which falls three stories
to hit him squarely in the forehead. That's enough
for severe facial trauma and bone fractures. Then
there are the paint cans both Bandits take to the
face, which could've taken their heads right off.
And let's not forget the crowbar that Marv uses
to whack Harry in the chest, which could've broken
his ribs, punctured his lungs, or pierced
his heart. And that's not even taking into
account all the other injuries both men likely
suffered as a result of Kevin's less lethal traps.
Somehow, we doubt that the McCallisters'
VCRs and jewelry were worth all of that.
"You guys give up, or you thirsty for more?"
While it's understandable why the police
don't seem to take Kevin's plight too
seriously earlier in the movie, it's a little
less easy to follow their process at the end.
After receiving Kevin's call that the Murphys'
house is being robbed, the police arrive
to discover Harry and Marv significantly worse
for wear, presumably still being watched over
by Old Man Marley and his shovel. Harry and
Marv are arrested, and Kevin watches from
the window of his house, where he then goes to
bed and peacefully awaits Christmas morning.
Why don't the police ever question Kevin? They
must've wondered why the Wet Bandits were so
beaten up, and in such a weird way, what with
the feathers and burn wounds on Harry and the
iron-shaped impression on Marv's face. Even if
Marley attempted to take responsibility for it,
the Bandits were fully conscious when the
police showed up, and they would likely
have been grumbling about the kid that did
this to them. It's bizarre that no one ever
comes to get Kevin's side of the story, and in
the process realize that he's home by himself.
If the police were better at their jobs, Kevin's
mom probably would've arrived home to an empty
house and the message that her son was at the
police station. Sure, it would've taken away
from the moving family reunion at the end, but
it would've helped with everyone's peace of mind.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.